yep we're gonna watch all of us are dead
today
three is the number of the episode of
season one i caught myself before you
could correct me guys we are going to
watch this hit that like button
chew into it sink your bloody teeth into
that subscribe bell notification
full length watch as long as we sync up
with the time code for all of us are
dead or over at our patreon page massive
thank you to
one of you who has joined our patreon
page are you the lucky super reject
patient zero also the boys at prepper
guys we are creating milestones together
and in time
you will be forgotten but we will live
on and get all the credit for your work
[Music]
jaden emperor thom
you
will be
forgotten
[Laughter]
[Music]
are you pregnant or something
[Music]
toilet baby so she was pregnant and
didn't know it i i guess so
i look pregnant oh i know wow that
jacket helps
what should do with the baby yeah put it
in her backpack
you're such a meanie
you're the real bully
oh
maybe in time he swings down and grabs
him and maybe
he's got his own hoses
i wonder what the point of that girl
having the babies
he caught the thing that's not what the
last scene made it look like yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
don't get it in your eyes bro
oh no
you're amazing there's an action hero
over here
i think that rope would break by now
my god you are so annoying
[Music]
i'm pretty sure a lot of people are
thinking
that's who she left the note for
good thing this pregnancy distracted you
from all this stuff
oh good job
[Music]
what just happened i can't be killed
oh man
[Music]
oh she got the baby
oh
are they climbing it
aim for the head
come on you know they're zombies stab
the head
[Laughter]
she lives on
she's gonna be the last zombie standing
in that series everything to grab yeah
no
no no i didn't even notice it until late
let it be a regular nosebleed
prove it
why don't you just give him a couple
minutes
watch his eyes
should i i was about to hate this cast
yeah just like throw them out the window
and they could still you never know
[Laughter]
you don't need to stay an hour
finally make some time to cut my mix
tape
i hope he's here till episode 12.
just under this table the whole time
five years after the apocalypse has
ended
full beard
day four thousand fifty-nine
[Applause]
get your revenge why does this bully
keep living
because he's a scoundrel
if you get her killed my dude oh you
this guy's
pissed me off so much the worst
how does he keep a living yeah
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
it's crazy how so many people still
don't know what's going on
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh man no one loves her kid more than
her
god damn it no
oh no
this show is going to destroy me
damn it no ma'am please don't go she's
going to save the day
i'm sorry
it's
[Music]
get in there man get in there you got
the words get in there
[Applause]
dammit
damn this [ __ ] is like non-stop this is
just escalating and escalating
oh no
cool
good luck team
oh no oh
serious has great zombie choreography
yeah
oh
[Music]
oh don't kill her off please
don't go find another way in
maybe her chicken is the cure
the spice
damn motorbike
don't
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh
so she's like the antagonist of the show
huh yeah so far
we're all watching
waiting for you to apologize
is he gonna accept what's in her pocket
she coulda she gonna shank him
this way this unfolds
someone in there
is she trying to infect him what a [ __ ]
wow
i can't believe she's doing this
that's one of the most
hateable things i've
oh
dude
she just straight up killed him yeah
someone better find that [ __ ] rage
ask what was on that towel dude give him
a clue
[Music]
that's unfortunate
[Music]
oh
how weird
[Music]
oh man
[Music]
go be with your people now
you're free
damn that [ __ ] is [ __ ] cruel that is
oh god that is among the cruelest things
i've ever seen she just killed me
straight up
killed the guy
oh no it's
our nose is starting to bleed
[Music]
[Music]
would that
hold
definitely
[Music]
goddamn korean shows and your [ __ ]
bleakness
crushing anguish yes
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh yeah that's right she was paying
attention oh thank god someone was
basically just christ let her figure
this out
um
well that's not very inconspicuous if
she's just in the back there watching
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
profusely
[Music]
okay
semantics
[Music]
wow
it shows something
it is
oh yeah
man
somehow this [ __ ] is going to make it
till the very end
just going to fly in episode 12 in a
chat
oh god
um
[Music]
oh she felt so much safer when she was
around yeah
[Applause]
[Laughter]
what a transition i didn't even care the
helicopter was there
yeah
we're all dead in the inside anyway
i finally have a shot at escaping
damage done
all right let's look up some character
names
while i think
that
gathering name here
lenayon
i don't know if anybody will begrudge
you but yes i i think yeah
um
yes
while i think her acting is quite
splendid and really brings this level of
like this this strange level of
narcissism where she just really views
herself as the victim in all
circumstances yes and i think it's it's
a strong performance where she just
can't admit her wrongdoings
um
i don't feel
the slightest bit of pity for her
i i can't stand her i can't like she she
sort of killed the guy because she just
felt like
she was already
people were harping on her for
being
totally mean and bullying
yeah
bullying him
and
so beca and because they were bullying
him and and she was heartbroken like
i thought she was being unreasonable and
she didn't like feel like she she put
herself in the position of i'm an
outcast here i'm like well you're you're
constantly pushing yourself to this
because of your the way you treat people
and especially this one guy
and then
come on resorts to killing him oh that's
insane to me that's that's nuts and
they're so cool it is it is interesting
it's a very fascinating series to me
about
like i don't know i i feel like i need
this
i would like to get the whole package
but the way they draw these parallels
between virus
and
the insidious nature of a virus
granted it's not super insidious to the
point of like it's insidious in the way
it spreads massively throughout
the quantity of individuals in the world
uh
however
the the insidious nature of what
this with the virus is and they also
draw this parallel with bullying yeah
it's really
like something i've never
would have
ever thought about
that's like a thing to draw like this
the buying this show the virus stems
from a means of protecting of
like the the anger within of this
retaliation whether that be through
self-harm or reflecting harm on others
is the parasite in and of itself at
least that's kind of what i'm gathering
from it is that's what's growing within
and is going to act out eventually yeah
so
yeah i don't know i don't know if the
themes or messages will become like
a little blurred by the end of it all
but
you know there's a lot of ground to
cover still to go yeah because they're
also still doing their zombie show yes
you know and there's also a certain
level of comment like there's a little
bit because we don't cut away from the
kids as much but there's a little bit of
that like government protocol commentary
too yeah and look
we're not
the people or well first to talk about
the social
kind of like social commentaries
specifically on
um you know like korean politics right
because we just don't know a lot of you
know there are things here that uh
happened like in the first episode that
a lot of you guys were telling us in the
comments are like actually this is
actually kind of normal
and bullying is a real problem yeah and
like while bullying's a problem out here
and and as well it's like the degree of
which people get a pass
like nuts to me uh to to know that like
yeah this is kind of how the society is
and you know and i and that's just
reflective of what people have said in
the comments so i don't know from like
watching documentaries or reading up on
things right
and uh so yeah i'm a little bit
trustious yeah i'm trusting those few
people
that's
yeah exactly white men from nebraska who
told us a lot about korea
uh yeah so
but there are universal themes that are
the things that that most click would
mean it is and it's just funny to see
someone once told me that it's always
stuck with me when i was like a teenager
someone told me that
um
when he graduated high school he
realized
that everything after high school is
high school
and that's really true like it this is
called like
gossipy
mean bullying ego status clicks yeah it
just doesn't you're like oh that's a
good
analogy it's always stuck with my whole
life since i since i heard that and then
you kind of even see that here with
drawing like we're looking at a school
and then we're looking at the politics
of the people who are quarantined here
at this hospital
like if you just told them who i was a
helicopter would be here but they're
both in pain
both of the status obsessed characters
who are
so well i mean she's somewhat of a
villain in that scenario not to the same
degree but yeah
yeah i don't know what that color what
does the color mean what does it
symbolize
i didn't i didn't mean necessarily that
like the i guess it to me visual
reflection i mean yeah to me it was just
like a visual thing to tie them together
somewhat subtly but also i don't know i
mean you could argue that it is a a fair
color uh you know used to then adorn
people who put on the errors of
eruditeness and who are actually quite
scoundrely underneath
nice thanks man trying out some new ones
thesaurus good investment
but yeah just read that thesaurus every
day and then i throw out a word and hey
if it makes sense awesome if it doesn't
try again
new word ever did yeah this was this was
interesting like i i like this one a lot
yeah i've heard some people say that
they think the beginning is
slow
which to me i was walking
i was ready to be like
let's pick this up like that's that's
where i was coming from uh like
especially by the time i got to the
third episode when i saw how high octane
the second one was
and and then uh here i i this one was
kind of haunting this was like really
uncomfortable and and uh
nerve-wracking
and
and and emotional too
you know just to be direct about it
because
then they're
locked in this room and like that's a
realistic choice like when you're just
going to walk around campus you know
yeah they're locked into this the safest
place and they still deal with like the
characters and and
how
that
they're re it's not a lot of times in
these survival stories what ends up
happening
is
the stuff before the outbreak
doesn't really matter it just it's like
it factors in
but it's really about let's just stay
alive yeah push everything to the side
right
and here they're doing something
interesting where they roll over these
dynamics
like a lot and they keep it
it's so integral to the story like this
whole thing with
you know
mean person calling him wealthy yeah and
dealing and again dealing with classism
as well
and
um you know feeling less than so
that carries over at this like thing
that just percolates throughout the
dynamic of this group
and
um this is a whole thing of like
isolation that happens amongst them yeah
but then when they're there it's like
when when our main guy
whose name i was hoping to pick up when
uh but there is uh
chung sun
uh when he is uh talking with
gyeongsu through the
in the recording
like that was a really endearing moment
and you could i thought the show drew a
really good tone at
even though i know they're here and
nothing's wrong with them why don't i
feel like something's like terrible is
about to happen yeah that whole scene
yeah it's it's fascinating because that
whole time he's in the booth i was
sitting there going something is really
wrong and yet i feel like he's not
infected yeah yeah and that gives like
that's some really solid direction i
feel like because yes eventually another
shoe does drop but even so to be able
just to suggest that based off of a
moment where things are actually fine is
pretty expert you know and the choi nam
ra character the class president
they like that's what i mean by drawing
these characters out so well is
she they establish her as someone who
doesn't interact
like in that first episode when
everyone's like getting invested in
other [ __ ] she's just doing her homework
still
uh when you know our stud muffin wants
to like pick her up on a date you know
she's just constantly playing her music
and just trying to move forward so she
just stays quiet and stay and observes
so establishing her as the one who would
be the one to pick up on
the uh the the handkerchief
is like that's well planted early on
that it's believable of like yeah she
would be the one to pay attention and
catch this yeah um at the same time it's
like the
the girl the [ __ ] character just
you know she's right there
yeah
yeah yeah one i mean i guess it's that
hubris of like you know i guess she's
not going to think that much of her or
of even her ability to observe because
you know she's not really concerned even
with her yeah but even just that like
they're great at lacing and yeah those
little details of like they have that
one shot where she looks at at the you
know mop and and and sees the severed
end of it and it's a great shot because
it makes you go
in the back of your mind you're like it
feels like there's more of a reason for
us to have held on that but also there's
the immediate reason of you know it it's
it's the you know smoking gun in the
room it's the big question mark of like
whose blood is that on the end of that
you know uh thing
but yeah like that was
it's funny because this episode starts
with the reversal where you have uh you
know chunks on not dying sworn he like
just straight up fell out like it really
looked like i need to like go back and
watch that yeah at the beginning of this
one there it's very like it's such a
quick shot like they show the way he's
falling that i think he does like kind
of
like throw the top of his body kind of
upward toward where the hose is but
either way it's never so clear that it's
like
not
that thing where they're trying to shoot
it to look worse than it is to get you
going oh no
um but it's like that reversal i feel
like as much as i am happy that you know
uh chunks on still here yeah like that
one is a little more hollywood-y to me
than the reveal with
uh namra actually catching
what uh you know uh nanyan was doing
yeah it's like that one was one where i
you know for at the end of the last
episode we were like oh god please don't
have just killed him it looks like he
killed him and for this one it's like oh
god please don't let her get away with
it looks like she can get away with it
um but i thought that one was a bit more
uh it has less of that hollywoodiness to
it even though it is still satisfying to
get that release
of tension and i feel like yeah that was
that was smartly done and just yeah like
the whole way they've drawn
the sort of shifting of the paranoia and
the whittling down of this group of
survivors we're following right now and
and how each episode like it's
fascinating to me the way that they're
able to do this show because each
episode ostensibly is a zombie movie
minus 10 minutes
and uh this whole show will be you know
a 10 12 hour zombie movie and
the way that from one episode to the
next it's so immediate and you still
have your central characters and yet the
spotlight still shifts around
you know and they're able to anchor you
on certain characters as your mains but
then also really you know gracefully
explore like it's it seems like they're
really able to have their cake and eat
it too in terms of like there is
absolutely no shortage in any of these
episodes of crazy zombie violence in
action but there's also like a lot of
fraught paranoia and touching harsh
character beats and things like that
like it's
it's it's quite impressive to me what
they've been able to do here and i'm
surprised when people are like yeah you
know the drama is kind of boring but the
zombie stuff's amazing
because i'm like dude
i've just seen was one of the most tense
things that like th
this is the [ __ ] that gets you
my mind started racing i'm like will
they ever find out i know and and
you know i'm curious because the show
seems like there are times when it's
willing to get that bleak and i feel
like there's an argument to be made for
maybe no one should have ever discovered
it and what does that say but uh but
yeah like they they really are not
afraid to go pretty harsh you can't have
that girl on your team no
well who knows though who knows what's
gonna happen with her miss park like you
know cause i'm sure she doesn't want her
to go die i'm sure that's why she went
out there so yeah i know the whole point
she's trying to save her yeah so
i i would fully expect them to do that
to us to bring her back somehow
to the group
but i don't know
ah it's so frustrating she did that i
really liked that guy too i didn't know
they were in my heart when he was like i
i i thought that scene was so powerful
his acting they were so good of like
just this
this immense level of confusion
like wow why because he's so disoriented
over i don't understand like i never got
bit how could this have happened
chiang's sun's looking at him like yeah
you weren't bit i don't i don't get like
everyone is just bewildered by this yeah
oh boy it was so it and
as the audience you know what happened
and so it's just like it just [ __ ]
with you on so many levels yeah because
you're like god damn it right there
she's just like take him out yeah i was
right scene
yeah and it's such a good dastardly plan
like it's so and it's just like a hyper
hyper um
uh
um oh my god i'm sorry it started
blinking right there uh what i'm trying
to say this has a hyper illustration of
you know bullying yeah let me use this
virus to bully a kid out of here well
perpetuate even beyond bully yeah just
to perpetuate like these really toxic
prejudices and these parts to go even a
step beyond or more broad just yeah like
the parts of the
previous normal life you led that now
you can't let go of in face of this
crazy crisis yeah that people cling to
in
you know face of things like that i like
the realism of that of like they they
knock a guy out and then you know
they're like where you bit let's all
check what's the way what's okay
everyone can check to make sure so we
all feel comfortable yeah yeah so what
do we all know it takes five minutes
yeah okay
i love those realistic touches i really
do i i think those touches are great and
i think i'm like are these the things
people were saying were boring because
today i'm like that stuff's really
necessary to me to like include you know
some sometimes like there are some jokes
that i'm like we're just throwing in
jokes because we gotta have some jokes
sure this guy's having a cramp in his
legs like how many followers you got on
instagram oh wow i got so many messages
on facebook you know yeah well
it's so fleeting it's just it goes by so
fast and i'm not like cooling all the
jokes man yeah you know yeah yeah so i
don't know i mean i've been like really
engaged and i feel like it's kind of
been non-stop and i think the zombie
stuff is really well realized like it's
always really entertaining and
you could just what's cool about the
containment time when they are contained
in classrooms and such
is
you could always
feel the panic happening outside yeah
and so it keeps attention alive it's not
like
the walking dead we're here like
i mean i've heard it i've heard it's
going great again
but for many seasons it was like jesus
christ can we pick up the pulse a little
bit yeah i see you spinning your wheels
guys yeah yeah you were dragging this
out yeah where where is this you know
it's like you get like riots in the
streets you got chongson's mother and
they established that really early on
too of like i love you so much he named
you after the restaurant yeah named the
rest of it yeah right your name dude
that's how it was i named you after the
restaurant yeah yeah and i'm gonna put
your face on yeah i'm gonna put your
face on like so the second chance at the
school you know that old lady will be
like i'm getting i'm gonna go and then
the details of like she's bad she's so
she's so stressed that the second she
gets on her bike just falls over right
away you know i i love
i love that attention like to me that
that's really rich yeah um i don't
understand this whole thing with the
girl
being like having a baby and uh i don't
know what happened i don't know i mean i
feel like they got to unpack what
happened there
yes like um
doesn't seem like she's someone who's
all we've seen her do is be like i feel
sick and then she's walking away and has
a baby all of a sudden
and so we haven't seen like it's
did she have a boyfriend it was a
one-night stand yeah it was halted like
what's the deal here what's the i feel
like there's some like bigger commentary
they're doing with her the [ __ ] guys
baby that's what i've been assaulting
everyone so that's what i mean it's like
i don't know what the deal is and i
wanna and i wanna see how it
thematically falls in because right now
it's just some bleak ass situation that
i'm like i don't know who she is or
what's going on or why this is in here
yeah
i
it's yeah i agree it i really liked that
thread as part of the overall array of
store like i liked it as this almost
silent side story
and uh but i yeah i agree that like i'm
still sitting here going what is the
grander point of doing that because it
seems like it's very pronounced the way
she literally avoids being killed by
accident a couple very distinct times
and then you know in the process of
saving this baby she gets bit like off
screen
you know or in a moment where it's not
really pronounced and so it feels like
all those things were done uh you know
pointedly
and i'm just not a hundred percent sure
other than being sort of an interesting
little vignette amid all this that
reasonably could happen
yeah what's the greater significance of
that i'm not that familiar with
premature births not a doctor
i'm not a scientist so i don't know
uh it's just she she didn't look
pregnant and then she had obviously
there are babies who can live from from
being born early
uh but you know like she comes out
there's an umbilical cord and
the baby's like literally living and
breathing
sort of living through the day and night
you know
and so i was like okay i don't i don't
know what yeah sorry just kept raising
more questions of
what is what is this thing they're doing
here unless the mom is gonna come back
to the restaurant find the baby and then
maybe because i was thinking like a baby
is is among the worst things to have in
a situation like this because it's a
constant noise machine that's also got
you know scent and warmth and all the
things that zombies love and so part of
me was like oh god is she gonna have to
try and
you know nurture this newly born baby
well you know in a very terrible
situation to have to do that and now i'm
wondering maybe that responsibility will
transfer too
if she gets back in one piece which i
sure hope she does and i love that that
they
that they do take time to have
characters like that like i really yeah
love the humanity
of following the mom and the situation
that she is in and even though again the
main
portion of the show is at the school i
really appreciate it having that it
makes it all the more heartbreaking what
happens true uh you know and and then
the peril that you know that chung's son
is in and having you know that scare of
the last episode
you know um
he'll look
yeah he'll be fine
but yeah i know i love that i love that
uh
that thread with her i thought it was
great
very worried for mom
she had stephen young to show up in this
series that would be cool
yeah man season two should just be an
action-packed show this should be our
trainer pazomba peninsula yeah
the very last episode is the plane
chopper
we got the korean guy from the walking
dead i thought you died like four
separate times on that show
can't kill glenn
glenn's back
oh man i'll break the internet a little
bit that would be fun that'd be so funny
yeah i mean really you ready to tell me
then you call rick all this stuff for
bullying
this one guy's son being
made its way to atlanta or wherever the
hell the show is
you know it's all it takes somebody
getting on a plane you get that
infection
that'd be a crazy movie right a
slow-moving virus
we're just all like at once around the
world starts to break out
anyway every corner of of humanity
michigan
yes it starts in michigan it starts
in the michigans of the world is where
the north dakota yes
[Laughter]
anyway guys
thanks for being here we'll see you soon
[Music]